hey 42 here what is mankind's plan B for
when poor old Earth has ceased to be gun
to meet its maker run down the curtain
and join the choir invisible what
happens when earth is in X planet well
then it's time to hop over the fence and
set up camp in our neighbours garden
even if it is a red desolate wasteland
just over 78 million kilometres away
on average Mars isn't quite our closest
neighbor that's normally Venus depending
on its position in its orbit but Mars is
definitely the best candidate to sustain
life and we're not talking about just
going and living in a caravan full of
baked beans and oxygen we're talking
about a full proper civilization out
walking on the surface of the Red Planet
so is this really possible could we
actually make Mars into a place where
humanity could survive could we breathe
could we grow food are there any good
bars today we look at the steps we would
need to take to become the Martians of
the future now getting to Mars is
something of a challenge and it could
take anywhere between 150 to 300 days
depending on space traffic but this time
frame is perfectly manageable although a
bit boring the real issue here though is
getting the huge volume of stuff we'd
need to colonize from the surface of
earth out into space and then over to
Mars right now it costs around $25,000
to get just one kilogram into orbit
around Earth and although the money is
obviously an issue think of all the
resources time and dedication it takes
to launch just one rocket into space
never mind a continuous fleet of
spaceships traveling to Mars with
supplies think how much effort it was to
build the International Space Station
and that's only 400 tons that would
barely carry the toothpaste and peanut
butter needed by the Mars colonists one
proposed idea is to build a space
elevator it's a surprisingly simple
concept you just need a cable attached
to the earth that extends out beyond the
distance of a geosynchronous orbit by
that I mean the orbital distance where
satellite rotate at the same speed as
the earth so it stays in exactly the
same position out in space as a start of
the elevator back on earth the cable
would have a counterweight at the end
the counterweight would swing around
like a tetherball and the centrifugal
force would be enough to counteract the
Earth's gravity which would mainly be
acting on the lower end of the cable
having much less influence on the
further away parts and the counterweight
itself this will keep the cable taut and
now you could run an elevator up and
down it using much less propulsion and
you'd need for a rocket some estimates
say that it would bring the cost of
putting one kilogram of supplies into
orbit down from $25,000 200 250 the
obvious technical difficulty is building
a cable that would need to be around a
hundred thousand kilometres long but
with the development of materials such
as carbon nanotubes it's beginning to
look more and more possible the cable
cars called climbers would probably use
rollers to pull themselves up using
friction but there's a limit to how fast
they could go of the cable partly
because of the strength of the material
but also because as you get higher you
are picking up huge horizontal speed
caused by the rotation of the earth this
is called the Coriolis effect you also
need to power the climbers the journey
will probably take five days so you'd
even need a powerful nuclear reactor or
the most likely solution you could beam
the energy up to the climber using a
laser meaning less weight actually being
carried on the vehicle itself and more
room for snacks so if the elevator does
work and all we need to get material
into space is listen to a few days of
awful elevator music the next step is
sending everything over to Mars and this
is where the moon could come in very
useful the moon would never be able to
have an atmosphere so it's hopeless as a
colonization prospect but its lack of
atmosphere is actually a huge advantage
because it means there is no friction
the great science fiction writer r4c
claude discusses this in his nonfiction
collection voices from the sky
it's worth pointing out that he also
popularized the idea of the space
elevator in his 1979 novel The Fountains
of paradise one idea that Clark put
forward is that you could build a giant
space gun that would fire spacecraft
down a track on the moon's surface and
flinging them out into space the craft
would only need small propulsion rockets
to make adjustments for its entry into
Mars the space gun wouldn't be possible
on earth because the friction of the
atmosphere will create too much heat and
you'd probably kill about a million
pigeons every journey as well as
everyone bought but on the moon with a
track just 30 kilometers long you could
get the acceleration you need and remain
under the 10g that astronauts currently
experience when they leave Earth if you
weren't sending people you could use a
much shorter truck as well the
technology that we currently use for
maglev trains would work extremely well
for this purpose using a magnetic field
to both float the vehicle above the
truck and to pull it forward this is why
Elon Musk and others are looking into
creating vacuum train tunnels for
terrestrial transport know where equals
no friction speaking of Elon Musk the
amazing achievements of SpaceX on the
privatization of space travel is
probably what will make this whole
colonization project a reality we're
still going to need rockets at the very
least to build and maintain Space
Station's but when Falcon 9 landed on an
automated drone ship this April after
sending supplies on to the International
Space Station it showed us that we can
finally start reusing rockets
potentially turning a 60 million dollar
trip into just $600,000 for fuel and
maintenance to get started on Mars we'd
need some pre-made living spaces they'd
probably initially be something like
those put forward by the Mars one
project a small series of contained
compartments which you could link up
therefore it would be easy to just shut
off one part when you have a problem and
when it comes to keeping the astronauts
alive well Mars has some very important
features thanks to the work of the first
Martian the hard-working Curiosity rover
we now know that there are all of the
Bay
SiC elements we need in the ground and
the atmosphere so we can create
breathable air from what is already
there there is ice in the soil as well I
could be used both as drinking water and
to produce oxygen there's nitrogen in
the atmosphere so we could make our
favorite cocktail of Earth style more or
less so that's water and air covered but
what about food future colonization
attempts on Mars such as Mars one plan
to send the boatload well spaceship load
full of fresh food to the planet in
advance so we will be waiting for the
colonists when they arrive but when that
food runs out well let's say things get
pretty grim the Martians will live
mostly on a diet of algae and insects
food will be produced hydroponically
using artificial lighting Martian soil
will be used to grow plants and carbon
dioxide for the plants will be provided
from the Martin atmosphere the nutrients
for the plants however will come from
recycling human waste lovely and if we
move beyond just the basics of keeping
people alive what about things like
communication even though you've moved
millions of miles away your grandma is
still going to expect a call the
Christmas to explain why you aren't
married yet and why didn't you get a
real job rather than all this fancy
space nonsense depending on the relative
positions of Earth and Mars a message
traveling at the speed of light can take
between 3 and 22 minutes to go from one
planet to the other that means phone
calls are out of the question but
internet messaging will be fine so one
day the solar system will be cluttered
with a constant stream of emojis
so how's Mars desert icon skull and
crossbones sub face 1 over idea that our
4c Club put forward invoices in the sky
is that you could use lasers to be much
higher volumes of data across space if
you make use of the moon once again
lasers will be distorted by Earth's
atmosphere but you could use the moon as
a relay station so messages could be
sent that short distance to the moon via
radio waves and then converted to the
more powerful laser form and vice-versa
this means large data dumps of technical
information could be much easier and you
wouldn't need to limit the colonisers
communications so the Martin folks will
be able to send all the selfies that
they want for Mars back to earth yeah we
get it you guys are holding a Mars bar
on Mars very funny
but now we come to the really important
question can we make the whole planet
livable humans are actually pretty
limited in terms of the environments
they can survive it it's not just a
chemistry of the air but also the
temperature and the pressure that are
important of course we could spend all
our time and space suits but it wouldn't
really be a normal life Andy what make
Martian next top model' a whole lot more
repetitive besides no one wants to spend
all day in a suit the atmosphere on Mars
is mainly carbon dioxide and it's at a
far lower pressure than we have on earth
at our sea level the pressure is about
200 kiloPascals to make life easier we
normally refer to this as one atmosphere
the lowest pressure as puny humans can
breathe in or needed is about 0.4
atmospheres anything under 0.2 would
require was to wear the suit Mars is all
the way down at 0.01 atmospheres you
really don't want to go out in that in
1966 a technician with testing a
spacesuit in a vacuum chamber the suit
failed and there was a rapid loss of
pressure the man quickly fell
unconscious what he recalls that the
last sensation he had before he passed
out was feeling the saliva boiling of
his time so without a spacesuit on Mars
you would rapidly boil alive before
exploding dramatically to increase the
pressure of the atmosphere we would face
some major issues one of the biggest
being that Mars lacks Earth's powerful
magnetic field called the magnetosphere
the Sun creates a solar wind a stream of
matter such as protons electrons and
alpha particles that are sent out in all
directions the part of the earth facing
the Sun the day's side is shielded from
the particle breeze by the magnetosphere
and Affleck's much of it away keeping us
safe
some does enter through the poles and
this is how you get the Aurora otherwise
known as the Northern or Southern Lights
we believe Earth has this magnetic field
because of its liquid outer core the
moving molten metal deep inside the
earth acts like a dynamo just like how
the spinning metal of a bicycle wheel
creates an electrical field that can
power the light bulb Mars once had a
magnetic field too but eventually the
planets core cooled down and now its
core is totally solid so its magnetic
field with lost without the protection
of a magnetosphere the solar wind blows
away much of the atmosphere thinning it
out we have not yet come up with a good
solution to this problem what we do have
are a variety of ways that we could at
least create the atmosphere once again
and raise a temperature of the planet's
surface
the South Pole of Mars holds a lot of
frozen carbon dioxide if we could heat
the surface a few degrees the co2 will
be released into the atmosphere and
would then act as a greenhouse gas like
it does in a problematic way here on
earth this would then warm the planet
and you could use simple life forms like
phytoplankton to convert some of that
carbon dioxide into oxygen
you could then slowly introduce more
complicated organisms and carefully
build the ecosystem as our knowledge of
genetic engineering grows we will
probably be able to alter the organisms
to work better in each stage of the
changing environment we'll also be able
to make six armed monkeys orange
dolphins and dangerously fat mice just
because we can't plant it's funny so how
would we give the planet that initial
kick of energy to release all of co2 and
create the desired greenhouse effect
well one idea put forward is to just
bounce more sunlight up to the pole with
a series of giant mirrors we could use a
substance called PE T as you can stretch
it very thin whilst maintaining a
reflective surface it would be pretty
slow though and I'm not sure Mars would
want to be staring at its awful red face
in the mirror every day
a quicker method although much more
difficult would be to go asteroid
hunting if we could find a few massive
asteroids rich in ammonia since this is
also an excellent greenhouse gas and
snap them in to Mars then it would
really speed up the whole process but it
would be a bit more complicated than
just sticking some cheese on a big stick
and hoping the asteroids are lured
across the solar system we need to play
a gigantic game of pool bouncing smaller
asteroids into bigger ones to put them
on the path that we want but all of
these challenges are just going to make
us push all that bit harder to find a
solution and every year new technologies
are emerging and new ideas and
approaches come from across the globe of
course we still haven't thought about
the question of Martian Society who
knows what new religions and cults will
spring up on the red planet and will it
be a separate nation and have a whole
new set of laws of its own well I have a
proper Jones who are all dying to know
but we'll just have to wait and see what
the next few decades brings I'd like to
thank Squarespace for supporting me on
this video which helps me to make better
content do you want to make a super
slick site without knowing all the
technical jargon well Squarespace makes
it super easy with them intuitive tools
you can make professionally designed
sites
super quick regardless of your
experience without writing a line of
code they'll even give you a free domain
name if you sign up for a year click the
link in the description to start your
free trial today at squarespace.com
forward slash 40 make sure you use the
offer code 44 10% of your first purchase
thanks for the view subscribe for more
welcome to the weirdest city in Alaska
Whittier
what Whittier is the city that forgot
how to city because it is home to just
220 people and they all live in one
building in 2006 a man from Portland
Oregon hired a hitman to kill his wife
his wife ended up killing the hit man
with her bare hands